if you were to put a probability on it
is it more likely that we merge with AI
or AI replaces us
a lot of people just think computers
come along they compete with them we
can't really compete and that's the end
of it
uh as opposed to them increasing our
abilities
and if you look at most technology it
increases our abilities
um
I mean look at the history of work
look at what people did a hundred years
ago
does any of that exist anymore people
I mean if you were to predict
that all of these jobs would go away and
would be done by machines people say
well that's going to be no one's going
to have jobs and
it's going to be massive unemployment
um
but I show in this book that's coming
out
of the amount of people that are working
even as a percentage of the population
has gone way up we're looking at the
x-axis Year from 1774 to 2024
and on the y-axis personal income per
capita in constant dollars and is
growing super linearly I mean it's yeah
2021 constant dollars and it's gone way
up
that's not what you would predict
given that we would predict that all
these jobs would go away
yeah but the reason it's gone up is
because we've basically enhanced our own
capabilities by using these machines as
opposed to them just competing with us
that's a key way in which we're going to
be able to become far smarter than we
are now by increasing the number of
different parameters we can consider in
making a decision